احييكم مشاهدينا مساء الخير انا ميسون
نواهد واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه كالعاده
نبدا بابرز العناوين
عائلتنا الترفض استغلال مقتله لتبرير
العنف في انحاء فرنسا والشرطه تنشر
الالافر رغم الهدوء الحذر
تكشف دوافع شديده لتمرد قائد فاجنر بينها
رفض وزاره الدفاع توقيع عقود مع مطاعم
يمتلكها بحسب موسكو
النفط في ليبيا عنوان ترشق جديد بين
الخصوم مباشره تحذر من ايقاف انتاجه
وبصفته مالكا للمنصه ايلون ماسك يقيد عدد
التغريدات المسموح بقراءتها يوميا
والمستخدمون غاضبون
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم هدوءن يمكن وصفه بالحذر في مدننا
وضواحي فرنسا بعد ايام من العنف مدينه
فرضت حضره جول ليلي على القاصرين لمده شهر
اما رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه اليزابيث
فاعلنت ان العنف لن يمر وسيتم التعامل معه
بسرامه كما اكدت جهوزيه الاجهزه الامنيه
لمواجهه العنف مضيفه انها اعطت تعليماتها
للدرك باستخدام المركبات الموصفحه من
جهتها دعت جدت نائل الفتى الذي قتل على يد
الشرطه الى عدم استغلال حادثه حفيدها من
المحتجين
وطالبتهم بالتوقف عن اعمال العنف
جزاء بوليفيا انا غاضبه من ضابط الشرطه
الذي قتل حفيدي ومن حسن حظنا ان لدينا
الشرطه والاشخاص الذين يدمرون الاشياء
اقول لهم توقفوا انهم يفعلون ذلك مع نائل
كذيعه يجب على الناس ان يتوقفوا يجب الا
يكسروا نوافذ المتاجر يجب الا ينهبوا
المدارس ان الامهات هن من يستقللن
الحافلات وهن من يسرنا في الخارج يجب ان
تهدا الامور لا نريدهم ان يكسروا الاشياء
نائل مات هذا كل ما في الامر
لا يعلن خمس مشاهدينا مضت تخللها شغب
واعمل عنف جعلت شوارع باريس وضواحيها لوحه
مشتعله في وجه انتشار امني كبير اعمال
كشفت بل كشفت مره اخرى عن توترات حاده في
البلاد التي تجذرت في الاحياء الفقيره وفق
تحليل نشرته صحيفه
وبحسب الصحيفه تظهر ان الاحياء الفقيره
والمختلطه عرقيا في فرنسا لا تزال تعاني
الشعور بالظلم والتمييز العنصري لكن رغم
فراحه اعمال الشغب التي تشهدها فرنسا الا
انها لم تصل بعد الى مستوى عنف الاحتجاجات
التي وقعت في عام 2005 عندما جرى احراق
اكثر من عشره الاف سياره وتضرر اكثر من
230 مبنى عاما ومنذ العام 2017 وماكرون
يحكم فرنسا بانيا خطابه السياسي على ان ما
يقوله انه جمله من الانجازات التي تحققت
اقتصاديا واجتماعيا ولا سيما الانخفاض في
معدلات البطاله بين الشباب بشكل عام لكن
الفقر المتاصره والتمييز العنصري وضعف
الاداء التعليمي هي قضايا باتت تثير
الشارع وتجعل من احتياجاته اكثر حديه
[موسيقى]
مظاهر العنف في الشوارع الفرنسيه اصبحت
مشهدا معتادا بعدما تحولت قضيه مقتل
الفتناء على يد الشرطه محركا لسلسله من
الاحتياجات واعمال شغب ومواجهات بين
الشرطه الفرنسيه وابناء الاحياء المهمهشه
مراسله العربيه زينه عاديه رصدت بعضا من
المخلفات نتابع مع حلول الليل يتحول هذا
الحي في ضاحيه كولوم شمال غرب باريس الى
ساحه حرب ساخنه مشهد الدمار خلفي ما هو
الا نتيجه لتلك الاشتباكات كان من المفترض
ان تساعد هذه الورشه التي حرقت على انشاء
سكه قطار جديده لكن اعمال العنف التي
اشعلها مقتلونال حاله دون ذلك وحولتها الى
حطام
صعب جدا على السكان يوجد الكثير من العنف
في الايام الاخيره هنا في المدينه بدا
بغضب الشبان من مقتل نائل على يد شرطي
نونتير ثم تفاقم فيما بعد وانتشر العنف
بطريقه غير مقبوله لانه يتعب العائلات
كثيرا
طبعه الاف شرطيا ودركي في باريس ومحيطها
فقط من اصل 45 الفا سينتشرون في جميع
الاراضي الفرنسيه في الليله السادسه
لاندلاع المواجهات بين الشرطه والمحتجين
من باريس ينضم الى مراسله العربيه فادي
دهوك فادي اهلا بك معنا منذ قليل
كيف كانت الاجواء هناك والان ايضا انت في
باريس كيف تبدو الصوره لديك
[موسيقى]
نعم ميسون الوضع مشابه قليلا لما هو في
مونتير هناك هدوء في تلك المنطقه وايضا
هنا حتى الان في العاصمه باريس في جاده
هناك انتشار امني فقط تحسبا لخروج تظاهرات
او وصول اشخاص يريدون القيام باعمال العنف
هنا ايضا يقوم الان عناصر الشرطه
بتفتيش بعض او شابين كان في هذه في هذه
الجاده طبعا هذه احدى الممارسات التي
يعترض عليها سكان الضواحي ان الشرطه تقوم
عندما تقوم بالاشتباه بهؤلاء بانهم قد
يقوموا باعمال العنف تبدا بتوقيفهم
وتفتيشهم وكما رايتم تركوهما
يذهبان في سبيله ما لم يجد معهما شيء الان
الوضع ما يزال هادئا في العاصمه هو كان
هادئا في عموم انحاء البلاد هذا اليوم وهي
وهذا اليوم الثاني الذي يكون فيه الهدوء
سيده الموقف او الاشتباكات على ان لم تكن
بالحده ذاتها التي كانت قبل ثلاثه او
اربعه ايام طبعا هناك 45 الف شرطي اعلن
وزير الداخليه جيرال درمنا نشرهم في مختلف
انحاء البلاد وسبعه الاف منهم في العاصمه
باريس لم تتخذ اجراءات اضافيه سوى ان هناك
طائرات درون سوف تحلق فوق العاصمه باريس
لمراقبه الشوارع ومراقبه تحركات الاشخاص
الذين
يتواجدون في شوارعها ميسون بالنسبه
للمحال والمباني التي تعرضت لاعمال تخريب
هل بداوا بتاهيلها من جديد ام هناك يعني
في هذه المناطق ما زالت الاجراءات الامنيه
تحد من التحرك فيها
الوضع في تلك المناطق ما يزال حساسا هناك
فقط محاولات لرفع انقاض من بعض الشوارع
التي احرقت فيها مركبات وسيارات كثيره
خصوصا في الضواحي مثل ضاحيه كولومب حيث
كانت زميله زينه اليوم وايضا في بعض
الضواحي الاخرى القريبه لكن على سبيل
المثال هناك حي بابلو بيكاسو حيث ولد نائل
وخرجت منه هذه شراره العنف ما تزال هناك
عشرات السيارات المتفحمه في الشوارع لا
يمكن الوصول الى هناك من قبل فرق البلديه
لتقوم
برفع هذه السيارات لان الوضع الامني ما
يزال غير مستقر هناك تجري اشتباكات ليليه
ليلا مع الشرطه حتى ان الشرطه لا تستطيع
التوغل والبقاء في داخل الحي لتحكم
السيطره عليه بشكل كامل سكان الحي وخصوصا
الشبان الذين يقولون انهم اصدقاء نائل
ويقومون بهذه الاعمال انتقاما له هم الذين
ي اولهم الغلبه في ذلك الحي في حي
ضاحيه مونتير غربي باريس
مدرعات الشرطه بدات تصل الى تلك المناطق
منذ يومين وتحاول ان ترافق قوات الشرطه
التي تتقدم بداخله سيرا على الاقدام لان
تضاريسه صعبه لا يمكن لاي سياره ان تدخل
هناك لكن هذه المدرعات نجحت في التقدم
كثيرا بداخله وساعدت عناصر الشرطه على
القيام ببعض عمليات الاعتقال ومن ثم
الانسحاب بسلام كذلك فادي طبعا نحن بموسم
فرص وفرنسا هي قبله سياحيه للناس هل تاثرت
الحركه ايضا وخاصه جاده وكل الاماكن
والشوارع التي تقتضى عاده بالسياح
حتى الان لا يبدو ان الحركه تاثرت بشكل
كبير هناك الكثير من السياح الذين نراهم
يتجولون حولنا برغم الانتشار الامني
الكثيف حتى انه يوم امس عندما كانت هناك
هناك الكثير من قوات الشرطه منتشره وتغلق
الحي احدى السائحات سالتني ما الذي يجري
فعندما شرحت لها قالت لي دعنا نرى هذا
العرض وكانت سعيده جدا بما يحدث وتضحك لكن
طبعا هناك بعض الانباء عن ان عدد كبير من
السياح الغوا حجوزاتهم
للشهر القادم في فرنسا لكن حتى الان
الامور تبدو طبيعيه برغم ان هناك عدد من
الاضطرابات في الضواحي وفي شوارع عديده من
العاصمه وايضا المدن الاخرى لكن الحركه
او خطاب مرتقب ولكن لم
نتابعها او نسمع اي معلومات عنه هل هناك
اي تسريبات حول هذا الاجتماع او
حول كلمه مكروم
الاجتماع انتهى تقريبا قبل ساعه من الان
استمر لساعه ونصف ولم يخرج اي تصريح بعده
غادر الوزراء من دون الادلاء باي تصريح
الفكره من هذا الاجتماع كانت بحسب ما تسرب
الى وسائل الاعلام ان يؤكد الرئيس على
الحزم وعلى وحده الصف وحده صف وزاراتها
خصوصا وانه جمع عدد من الوزراء المعنيين
بهذه الازمه مثل رئيسه الوزراء وزير
الداخليه وايضا وزير العدل لم يخرج حتى
الان اي تصريح عن هذا الاجتماع الذي عقد
اليوم لخليه الازمه شكرا لك من باريس
مراسل العربيه فادي الدهوك على كل هذه
التفاصيل وعلى الصوره الواضحه حقيقه عما
يجري اليوم في فرنسا
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه العالمه في فرنسا
واعمال الشغب عقب مقتل الشاب نائل بالرصاص
الشرطي سلطت الضوء مجددا على الضواحي
الفرنسيه وخصوصا على ما يسمى الاحياء ذات
الاولويه نتابع ابرز الارقام والاحصاءات
التي تخص هذه الاحياء المحروقه
في فرنسا خمسه ملايين ومائه الف شخص في
احياء فقيره اي حوالي ثمانيه في المئه من
السكان حسب بيانات معهد الاحصاء الفرنسي
لعام 2023 في 2014 حددت الدوله
1514 حيا فقيرا الاحياء بمجملها مناطق
سكنيه واسعه في ضواحي المدن الكبرى او
مناطق صناعيه سابقه نحو 23% من سكان هذه
الاحياء لم يولدوا في فرنسا متوسط الدخل
المتاح في الاحياء الشعبيه حوالي 13 الف
يورو سنويا لكل اسره وواحد وعشرين الف
يورو في المناطق المحيطه بها معدل الفق في
الاحياء الشعبيه اعلى بثلاث مرات من اي
مكان اخر في فرنسا سنه 2019 في عام 2020
معدل البطاله اعلى بكثير في الاحياء
الشعبيه بلغ
18.6% من القوى العامله مقارنه بثمانيه في
المئه على المستوى الوطني في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2017 امتنع 48% من سكان هذه
الاحياء البالغين عن التصويت او لم يسجلوا
في القوائم الانتخابيه وفق معهد مونتين
عام 2020 فيما انخفضت هذه النسبه الى 29%
في بقيه فرنسا استثمرت الحكومه نحو 12
مليار يورو في 600 من الاحياء الشعبيه بين
عامي
2020 وتعتزم استثمار 12 مليار يورو اضافيه
بحلول عام 2030
[موسيقى]
الى شان الروسيه الان حيث انتهى التمرد في
روسيا ولكن لم تنتهي بعد فكل يوم تتكشف
معلومات جديده حول قضيه هذا التمرد
وتحركات قائده
والجديد اتهام احد الاصوات المؤيده للكريم
لانديمتري
بانه انحرف عن موقفه بعدما تلقى اكثر من 8
مليار يورو في المال العام واضاف ان
الشعور بالاعتقاد بان كل شيء متاح ظهر منذ
فتره طويله عند بدء عمليه في سوريا
وافريقيا وتعزز بعد ان استولى على مدينه
تيسوليدار في اوكرانيا اما سبب تمرد
فاغنور عزاه كيسوف الى رفض وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تمديد العقود الكبيره الموقعه مع
مجموعه كونكورد للمطاعم التي يملكها
بالنسبه
خصم موسكو علقت وعلى لسان مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه على
التمرد فاغنر حيث قال تمرد المسلح الذي
نفذه في جورجين كان بمثابه تحد للدوله
الروسيه واظهرت تاثير المدمر لحرب الرئيس
الذي في اوكرانيا
بعدما وصف هذا المنطق بالكاذب وراى مدير
وكاله الاستخبارات ان استياء في روسيا اثر
حربها على اوكرانيا يمثل فرصه نادره
لتجميد الجواسيس بل وذهب الى ابعد من ذلك
قائلا ان الوكاله الامريكيه لن تترك هذه
الفرصه تضيع هباء
حقيقه ليست موسكو وحدها من لعبت دور الظل
فقد سلط تمردها الاخير الضوء على الدور
الذي تلعبه شركات الامن الخاصه في بلدان
اخرى بينها مثلا الصين التي تنشر قوات
امنيه في انحاء من افريقيا وايضا من اسيا
صحيفه
نشرت تقريرا عن الاختلافات بين مجموعه
فارني الروسيه وشركات الامن الصينيه التي
تعمل في الخارج قائله ان هذه الشركات
الامنيه تحرس مصالح ومشاريع صينيه ورجعت
الصحيفه توسيع دورها من قبل الحكومه
الصينيه مع زياده النقود الصيني كما اورد
التقرير ان النسختين الروسيه والصينيه
تتميزان بعلاقات غامضه مع جيوش دولها
وتنفذاني مهام سريه ولهما نقاط دفاعيه
بحريه في اماكن نفوذهما لكن الصحيفه
تستدرك بالقول ان الحزب الحاكم في الصين
هو ذو السلطه مركزيه ولا يترك مجالا كبيرا
لشركات الامن الخاصه لشن عسكري كما فعلت
بادنر في روسيا وعلى عكس قوه المقاتله شبه
العسكريه والمجهزه للحرب تتولى شركات
الامن الصينيه في المقام الاول مهام
الحراسه التي لا تتطلب اسلحه فتاكه اما
اذا طلب منها تولي مهام اكثر خطوره في
الخارج فان عناصر هذه الشركات يعملون
كمستشارين بتوظيف واداره الموظفين
المحليين الذين قد يحملون سلاح
يبدو بان روسيا تتجه لاحتوائف وفقا لما
اظهرته لقطات لازاله لافتات للمجموعه من
مبنى مقرها الرسمي الاول في سانتي برج
الروسيه وداهمت الشرطه الروسيه بمبنى الذي
افتتح في نوفمبر من عام 2022 في يوم
الرابع والعشرين من يونيو الماضي بعدما
تمرد بل بعد تمرد قوات مجموعه العسكريه
وكان زائد يعتبر المبنى خطوه رئيسيه لنشر
اوراق اعتماد العسكريه والقيام بدورها
علنا في تشكيل السياسه الدفاعيه لروسيا
اذا وجود مجموعه
ايضا دفع تلك الدول للتعبير عن خشيتها من
انشطه التخريبيه قد تنفذها قوات فاغنر
انطلاقا من بيلاروسيا بحسب تلك الدول
وساطه بيلاروسيا توقف الزحف الى موسكو
وتبث الفزع لدى الدول المجاوره بولندا
ودول البلطيق يطرق ابوابهم وصفوه بالتهديد
المحتمل باقتراب مجموعه فاجنر من حدودهم
بعد التمرد وانتقالهم الى بيلاروسيا بعد
وساطه رئيسها ومع استشعار بولندا ما تصفه
بالخطر قررت ضم 500 عنصر من افراد الشرطه
من بينهم وحده لمكافحه الارهاب اضافه الى
خمسه الاف فرد من قوات حرس الحدود والفي
جندي لحراسه حدودها فالحدود بين البلدين
والتي يصل طولها لاكثر من 400 كيلومتر
لطالما ابتسمت بالتوتر خلال السنوات
الماضيه بسبب تدفق المهاجرين نحو اوروبا
وعاده ما تكون بيلاروسيا هي المتهمه
بتسهيل تدفقهم الى بولندا انتقاما
للعقوبات الغربيه المفروضه على منسك
الخوف من تهديد فاجنر يمتد لدول البلطيق
في استونيا ولاتفيا وليتوانيا التي تشعر
بقلق من ان تصبح على تماس مباشر مع
المجموعه تحديدا لتوانيا التي لديها اطول
حدود مع بيلاروسيا للطبع رامه من جانبها
قررت العوده لنظام الخدمه الاجباريه
العسكريه رغم وضعها في الحسبان ان يتجاوز
تهديد فاجنر السياق العسكريه المباشر الى
تسلل اشخاص لاوروبا لاهداف غامضه
مخاوف تزامنت مع محاوله نحو 190 شخصا
العبور الى بولندا بشكل غير قانوني من
بيلاروسيا وفقا لتقرير رويترز
التطورات بالقرب من دول الجناح الشرقي
لحلف الناتو تاتي قبيل قمه الحلف المرتقبه
في يوليو الحالي والتي قد تدفع الحلف
لتحقيق رغبه تلك الدول بنشر المزيد من
قواته على اراضيها
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان الحاح اوكرانيا على الانضمام لحلف
الناتو لم يجد نفعا اذ نقلت مجله عن
مسؤولين غربيين قولهم ان حلف الناتو لن
يمنح اوكرانيا العضويه وانما سيمنحها
ضمانات امنيه طويله المدى واشارت المجله
الى ان ضمانات النيتو لكاب ستشمل الاسلحه
والمساعدات والعمل الاستخباراتي لسنوات
قادمه كما بينت ان امريكا تخشى من الدخول
بحرب مع روسيا اذا تماما فاوكرانيا عضويه
حلف الناتو
[موسيقى]
وفي مقابله صحفيه ردا على سؤال عما اذا
كانت المانيا ستزود اوكرانيا بصواريخ تروس
بعيده المدى اكد المستشار
الالمانيين لا تريد ان باسلحه يمكن
استخدامها لمهاجمه روسيا
[موسيقى]
ايضا المدرعات الفرنسيه المقدمه لكاف
تعاني من مشاكل مختلفه على جبهه القتال
ابرزها ضعف التصفيح وعدم الملائمه لشن
الهجمات عيوب كشفها قاده في الجيش
الاوكراني بعد استخدامها على طول جبهات
المواجهه المبتسمه بالقصف العنيف والكثيف
على خط الجبهه كي ترفع اشاره النصر وتغير
اتجاه المعارك وجب عليك امتلاك اسلحه
متطوره قادره على مواجهه العدو في
اوكرانيا القاعده لا تتغير مدرعات
المقدمه من باريس تعاني ضعف التصفيح ما
يجعلها غير ملائمه للمعارك على خط
المواجهه بحسب قاده ميدانيين اوكرانيين
استخدموها في محاور القتال ضد روسيا وفق
الجيش الفرنسي فان مدرعه اي ام اكس 10 ار
سي تزين 20 طنا ويكفي تصحيحها للتصدي
لاسلحه المشاه الخفيفه تعمل القوه
الفرنسيه بشكل تدريجي على استبدال هذه
المدرعات التي تعود الى السبعينات من
القرن الماضي باخرى حديثه من طراز جاكوار
ورغم ان هذه المدرعه المستخدمه في عمليات
قصف مسانده مسلحه بشكل جيد الا ان انفجار
القذائف بقربها تسبب في مقتل طاقمها بعد
اختراق الشظ امر ادى ايضا لانفجار مخزون
القذائف بها فار ارسال هذه المدرعات
للهجوم يبدو بدون فائده بل يشكل خطرا على
الطاقم بالدرجه الاولى وبحسب قاده
ميدانيين بالجيش الاوكراني فان المدرعه
البريطانيه والامريكيه ذات فاعليه اكبر
وقدره على تحمل العبوات الناسفه والكمائن
ما يجعلها مفضله لدى الجيش الاوكراني في
مواجهه الجيش الروسي في ميدان المعركه
بلال البجداني العربيه
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعض لحظات الاف
الاسري تفر من السودان واليونيسف تبدا
بجهود جديده لتطويق الاسماء ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه افادت
مصادر العربيه بتدهور الوضع الصحي لهانبال
القذافي نجل الزعيم الليبي الراحل معمر
القذافي ونقله للمشفى لبنان واضافت مصادر
العربيه ان هانيبال يعاني من انخفاضا حاتم
مستوى سكر الدم ووضعه الصحيحرج ويخوض نجم
القذافي اضرابا عن الطعام منذ نحو خمسه
اسابيع احتجاجا على توقيفهم منذ ثمان
سنوات بتهمه كتم معلومات تتعلق باخفاء رجل
الدين في ليبيا عام 1978 وفق صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط
[موسيقى]
نتابع من ليبيا ايضا حيث اعلنت القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه الليبيه ان قائد
الجيش خليفه حفتر اصدر تعليمات الى مصلحه
الطيران المدني بفتح مطار الابرق شمالي
ليبيا والبدء بتسيير الرحلات الداخليه
والدوليه من خلال تعليمات وحفتر تهدف وحسب
قياده الجيش الى رفع المعاناه وتخفيف
الاعباء عن اهالي المنطقه الشرقيه في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
ايضا في ليبيا هناك صراع يلد اخر فمن جديد
الاطراف المحليات والتنبري الى تراشق
وصراع عنوانه اليه توزيع واردات بيع النفط
السبب تصريحات المبعوث الامريكيه الخاص
لدى السفير تشيرنورلاند بشان النفط الليبي
الذي طالب فيه بعدم التهديد باغلاق النفط
لما له من تداعيات اقتصاديه وسياسيه الامر
الذي اثار حفيظه البرلمان الليبي حيث ادان
70 نائبا التصريحات مشددين على تاييدهم
قرار الحكومه الليبيه بالحجز الاداري على
اراده النفط وبررا نواب الاجراءات
القانونيه بالدفاع عن قوت الليبيين وكبح
جماح الفساد المتفشي في موارد الدوله
الليبيه الذي توج بالحجز الاداري على
ايرادات النصف وحكم المحكمه التي تعتبر
السلطه قضائيه مستقله بدوره اتهم رئيس
الوزراء الحكومه المكلفه من مجلس النواب
اسامه حماد المبعوثه الامريكي لدى ليبيا
بدعم طرف واحد يستفيد من اهدار اموال
الشعب الليبي واصالها باحترام لسياده
القضاء اللي
يبدو سيد مريم لا يا اسماعيل لا يسمعني
ساذهب الان الى ضيفنا سنوسي اسماعيل السيد
سنوسي هل انتم مع هذا التصريح الذي تحدث
به المبعوث الامريكي في ليبيا
تحيه لكم طيبه ولكل الساده المشاهدين
طبعا هو التدخلات من السفراء يعني هذا امر
تعودنا عليه طوال السنوات الماضيه وفما
بالك
بيستفيد الامريكي نورلاند لكن هو في تصوري
لا نستطيع ان
ان نرد او نلغي كل كلام نورلاند هناك بعض
ما ذكره بالفعل يعني امر يعني يتعلق
بمصلحه الشعب الليبي العليا في تدفق النفط
وعدم التلويح
باقفال النفط يعني في اي تحت اي ظرف من
الظروف لنقل
فهذه المساله لنقل انها صحيح انها تتعلق
بمصلحه الشعب الليبي العليا ولكن ايضا
لا ننسى دائما بان اشكاليه الانقسام
الحكومي
اسهم فيها المجتمع الدولي وبالتالي
كل ما نراه الان هو صراع بين حك كل حكومه
تريد ان تسيطر على موارد النفط ويبقى طبعا
الامر دائما مناط بمصرف ليبيا المركزي هو
الاخر الذي
يعني ربما يحاول ان يدعم هذه الحكومه او
تلك او انه
في بعض الجوانب صحيح انه يوزع الايرادات
في على بعض الابواب في الميزانيه على جميع
الليبين ولكن هناك ابواب فيها مشكله
بالفعل لانها تعبر عن عدم عداله في توزيع
المشروعات وفي توزيع الايرادات على كامل
جاهزه
نسمع رايه بما قاله المبعوث الامريكي
ولماذا هذا الرفض لمطالبه هل تسمعني الان
سيد مريم
يبدو بان ايضا فقدنا الاتصال به نحاول ان
نعود اليه في وقت لاحق ما هي الخيارات
الان سيد سنوسي امام
الاطراف الليبيه بموضوع النفط لانه هناك
يعني كما تحدث النواب بان هناك فساد
مستشري ويجب ان يعملوا على حمايه قوت
الليبيين ما هي الخيارات الان كيف سيتم
التصرف بهذه القرارات وخاصه بانه القضاء
مستقل يعني في ليبيا
هناك امر قضائي
نعم نعم هناك يعني احكام قضائيه
استصدرها اصدرتها وزاره الماليه في حكومه
البرلمان في بنغازي
واعتقد بانها يمكن ان
تشكل نوع من الضغط لنقل على حكومه السيد
عبد الحميد بيبي في طرابلس هذا مساله
مفروغ منها ولكن ايضا نضيف دائما بان
الليبي لا يريدون هذا الصراع ان يكون بهذا
الشكل فقط مجرد يعني
صراع من اجل السيطره على
اللي هو نفط دون ان يكون هنا دون ان يصحب
ذلك مكافحه للفساد سواء في طرابلس او في
بنغازي او في اي مكان لانه لا فائده من
الاموال سيد اسماعيل البعض يعتبره بانه
ايضا
محسوب على اشخاص معينين او البعض يعتبرون
بانه لا شرعيه في بعض الاوقات للقائمين
عليه من قادر على محاربه هذا الفساد من
اجل الحفاظ على هذا النفط ليستفيد منه
الليبيون
نعم هو يعني المساله هذه مساله قانونيه
صرفه يفترض يفترض النائب العام ولكن طبعا
نائب العام هو لا يستطيع ان يفعل كل شيء
نتيجه الظروف الانقسام في ليبيا وهذا وهنا
نتكلم عن دور المجتمع الدولي في مكافحه
الفساد كلما تحصل من
حديث عن ليبيا وعن المساله الليبيه في
مجلس الامن او في اي مؤتمر او كذا يتم
تناول هذه المساله ولكن دون وجود اي خطوات
ولذلك فنزيف الفساد مستمر في جميع انحاء
ليبيا وهذه مشكله كبيره لكن هنا ربما
المساله اثيرت هذه الايام هي مساله عدم
العداله في توزيع الثروه النفطيه بغض
النظر عن صراع الحكومتين اقول بالفعل هذا
يحتاج الى تفعيل ربما اليات تضمن يعني
توزيع الايرادات بشكل جيد
لا عن المركبات
وجهه نظر ولكن اسمحوا لي ان اذكر بهذه
الاخبار العاجله الوارده من فرنسا مراسل
العربيه يتحدث بانه ماكرون طلب من وزرائه
مواصله التعبئه حتى استعاده الهدوء الكامل
في فرنسا هذه ابرز النقاط نحن نعلم بانه
كان هناك اجتماع للرئيس ماكرون مع قياده
في او قاده في حكومتهم السيد المريم اتمنى
ان تكون تسمعني الان
واضح جدا نعم
البعض يعتبر بانه قرارات مجلس النواب بشان
عداله توزيع النفط هو بمثابه ورقه الضغط
هل هذا صحيح
مرحبا اهلا وسهلا بك سيدتي الكريم والسيد
اسماعيل وكل عام وانتم بخير بمناسبه عيد
الاضحى المبارك ونتمنى الشفاء حقيقه
لهنيبال القذافي الذي سمعنا منذ قليل منكم
بانه احيل الى المستشفى مريضا جراء السجن
الذي يعبق فيه منذ فتره علي اتحال حول
توزيع الثروه لا ليس
ضغطا ولكن هو مناداه ومطالبه حقيقه من كل
الاقاليم في ليبيا حول التوزيع العادل
للثروه النفطيه في في ليبيا
ومناداه شعبيه ومناداه من مسؤولين ومن
احزاب ومن مؤسسات مجتمع مدني ومن مكونات
اجتماعيه هذا منذ قيام هذه الثوره ثوره
فبراير وهم يطالبون
بالتوزيع العادل لهذه الثروه لانه
الايرادات النفطيه اسمح لي على سعر صرف
على سعر الصرف
الليره ايضا سيؤثر على حياه الناس وعلى
قوت الناس
يعني يطالبون بتوزيع عادل لهذه الثروه اما
فيما يخص ماذا تم من اجراءات
مجلس النواب شكا اللجنه للنظر في توزيع
الثروه في ليبيا من مجلس النواب وكذلك من
جهه اخرى لها علاقه بهذا الامر مؤسسه
النفط او من الماليه او من جهات اخرى لها
علاقه كما قلت لك بتوزيع الايرادات
النفطيه
لذلك
نعم نتحدث به المبعوث الامريكي البين لديه
معلومات يعني غير دقيقه لانه قال ايقاف
النفط وانما الحكومه او ما ايده مجلس
النواب وهو الحجز الاداري على الايرادات
النقديه من خلال القضاء الليبي حتى يتم
التوزيع الصحيح والعادل لان الحكومه
المتواجده حاليا
المنتهيه الولايه والتي يراس عبد الحميد
الدبيبه تعبث بالاموال الليبيه التي هي
ايراد النفط اللي بيريدون ان يحافظون على
ايراداتهم وذلك من خلال حجز
اداري قضائي حتى يتم التوزيع العادي
العادل ولكن بالنسبه لتدفق النفط وبيعه
وتصديره هذا كله يعني مباح ويستمر ليس
هناك اغلاق ولا تفكير في اغلاق ولكن
ايراداته ولكن ايراداته لابد وان تخضع
للاراده الليبيه من خلال المؤسساتنا
الحقيقيه توزيعها توزيعها عادل على الشعب
الليبي من خلال اقل مكوناتها
مجلس نواب الليبي كنت مع من غازي اشكرك
كما اشكر ضيفي من طرابلس المتحدث السابق
باسم المجلس الاعلى للدوله الليبيه
السينوس اسماعيل شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
الى السودان وجديد الصراعها فدى مراسل
العربيه باستمرار الاشتباكات العنيفه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في ام درمان والخرطوم
بحري ياتي ذلك وسط تحليق مكثف للطيران
الجيش الذي اكد امس انه ينفذ عمليات
النوعيه في
عده مناطق في الخرطوم بحر المجاوره
والمدينه الرياضيه وحي الشجره في الخرطوم
اشتباكات وقصفا مدفعيا قويا
[موسيقى]
مصادر عسكريه افادت للعربيه بان الجيش
السوداني اسقط مسيره التابعه لقوات الدعم
السريه بمنطقه بحر العسكريه نتابع
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
من العنف في اقليم غرب دار غربي السودان
وفخما قالت ممثله منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله اليونيسيف منديف اوبراين اوبرايم
قالت ان اليونيسيف عمليات توزيع الادويه
والادوات الطبيه الضروريه لعلاج الجرحى
والمرضى من الاطفال في غرب كما تشهد عده
مدن في غرب مواجهات داميه بعد ان تحول
الصراع المسلح في اقليم دارفور بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع الى مواجهات قبليه
[موسيقى]
تستعد اسرائيل لاستقبال صرب ثالث من
مقاتلات اف 35 الامريكيه بعد ابرامها صفقه
تبلغ قيمتها ثلاثه مليارات دولار حيث
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه عن شراء
25 طائره اف 35 ستصنعها شركه الامريكيه
هذه الصفقه سترفع اجماليه مقاتلي 35 في
سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي الى 75 طائره وفق ما
نقلت علما بان اسرائيل ستكون اول دوله غير
الولايات المتحده تحصل على مقاتلات افخم
وتوعدت باستخدامها في العمل القتاليه منذ
عام 2018
[موسيقى]
هذه هي اخبار عاجله الخارجيه السعوديه
تقول بين المملكه تؤكد رفضها القاطع لقيام
احد المتطرفين بحرق نسخه من المصحف وكان
ايضا هناك عاجل قبل قليل بانها استدعت
سفيره السويد في المملكه لدينا في اخبار
الساعه بعد لحظات برمجيات ذكاء الاصطناعي
تهدد نصف العاملين في البرمجه بالسوق
الامريكيه تفضلوا بالبقاء معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدرت حركه طالبان قرارا
يقضي باغلاق محل التجميل النسائيه والغاء
كافه تراخيصها التجاريه في افغانستان على
ان يطبق القرار في غضون شهر واحد بعد مهله
اقرها زعيم حركه طالبان ومن المقرر ان يتم
اغلاق محلات التجميل النسائيه بشكل نهائي
بحلول الرابع والعشرين من يوليو جاري
[موسيقى]
اجرى الملياردير الامريكي المثير للجدل
ايلون ماسك تعديلاتهم جوهريه منذ اتمامه
لصفقه شراء منصه تويتر اكتوبر العام
الماضي تغييرات كان اخرها تعديل سياسه عرض
التغريدات بشكل طارئ ومؤقت حسب ما اعلن
مازن هذا
منذ ان استحوذ الملياردير الامريكي ايلون
ماسك على تويتر في نهايه اكتوبر العام
الماضي وشهدت المنصه ثوره من التغييرات
تغييرات كان اخرها فرض قيود جديده على
المستخدمين بتحديد عدد التغريدات المسموح
برؤيتها يوميا فالحسابات الموثقه تقتصر
على قراءه سته الاف منشور والحسابات التي
لم يتم التحقق منها تقتصر على قراءه 600
منشور اما الحسابات الجديده ولم يتم
التحقق منها فلها رؤيه حتى 300 منشور
ماسك وصف الخطوه بالاجراء الطارئ والمؤقت
لمنع ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي من البحث في
تويتر واستخدام المعلومات التي تنشر عليه
قبلها تم التغييرات عديده ابرزها كان في
ديسمبر 2022
اعلن ماسك التنحي عن منصب الرئيس التنفيذي
لتويتر عند اي بديل بعد ان صوت مستخدم
تويتر في استطلاع للراي اطلقه هو بنفسه
على تنحيه وفي يناير 2023 اطلق ماسك
تعديلات جديده تغير شكل صفحه تويتر
الرئيسيه على الويب بهدف تحسين تجربه
التصفح على المنصه في مارس 2023 قرر ماسك
ان جميع اكواد المنصه الخاصه بتوصيه
التغريدات ستكون مصادر مفتوحه في ابريل
2023 نفذ ماسك تهديده بازاله العلامه
الزرقاء عن الحسابات التي لم تدفع الرسوم
البالغه ثمانيه دولارات شهريا وفي الشهر
نفسه عدل ماسك شعارا المنصه الى رمز عمله
دوجكوين المشفره قبل استعاده العصفور
الازرق مجددا
لم يعد اذن اي اعلان جديد لماسك يتطلب رفع
حاجب الدهشه بالنسبه لمستخدمه تويتر الذين
قالوا انهم باتوا يتوقعون دوما اي تغيير
من ماسك الموصوف بانه مثير للجدل
[موسيقى]
ما طورته ايديهم قد يقطعوا مصدر رزقهم
مبرمجوا ذكاء الاصطناعي حسب كل شيء الا ان
تصبح وظائفهم على المحك فشركات
التكنولوجيا اعتادت على توظيف اشخاص
المتخصصين بالبرمجه وكتابه الشفرات لتطوير
البرمجيات والحلول المختلفه لكن بعضهم
اصبح يعتمد على برمجيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
لتنفيذ عملهم بسرعه وبتكاليف قليله وفق
صحيفه
كشف ان الذكاء الاصطناعي يعمل على التشغيل
الالي للعمل المعرفي وهذا الامر سيؤثر على
نصف القوه العامله الامريكيه الذين يعملون
في هذه الوظائف في حين اظهر استطلاعهم
لشركه ستاك اوفر سلو ان حوالي 70% من 90
الف مبرمج شاركوا في الاستطلاع يستخدمون
حلول الذكاء الاصطناعي في عملهم فيما اشار
نحو ثروسهم الى ان هذه الادوات تجعلهم
اكثر انتاجيه
[موسيقى]
ختاما نذكر بعناوين اخبار الساعه
عائلتنا ترفض استغلال مقتله لتبرير العنف
في انحاء فرنسا والشرطه تنشر الالاف رغم
الهدوء الحذر
[موسيقى]
تكشف ودوافع جديده لتمرد قائد فاجنر بينها
رفض وزاره الدفاع توقيع عقود مع مطاعم
يمتلكها بحسب موسكو
النفط في ليبيا وعنوان ترشق جديد بين
الخصوم واشنطن تحذر من ايقاف انتاجه
بصفته مالكا للمنصه يقيد عدد التغريدات
المسموح بقراءتها يوميا
والمستخدمون غاضبون
اشكر لكم في المتابعه اترككم في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات